Laser cooling means shining light on
stuff and making it cold.
Now that in itself sounds like it's
completely backwards because after all,
you typically think if you shine light
on something,
it's gonna.
Get warm,
so how is it even possible to shine
light on something and make it cold to
cool the air down means to make those
molecules,
atoms in the air move more slowly.
That's the difference between hot and
cold.
So how do you make something cold with
the laser?
Well,
lasers,
all light pushes on stuff.
There's a thing called radiation
pressure.
White pushes on things.
What we've figured out to do over the
years is how to push on Adams in such a
way as to make them slow down.
The thing that was perhaps the.
The crowning achievement of the early
days of laser cooling was the discovery
that we made in our laboratory that it
was possible to get these atoms colder
than everyone had thought was the limit
to how cold you could get something.
The prediction said that we could get
down to temperatures of 240 millions of
a degree.
In other words,
one quarter of 1000 of a degree above
absolute zero,
pretty cold,
right?
Will in fact,
we've got a whole lot colder than that.
And that was the big breakthrough
discovery that made a whole lot of other
things possible.
Well,
all clocks have tickers.
All of these tickers have imperfections.
Every quartz crystal is made a little
bit differently of the length of the
pendulum can change a little bit on that
changes how fast it will swing back and
forth.
So all of these clocks have
imperfections and so one has throughout
history been trying to make these clocks
better by making the tickers be more
reliable.
That is always had the same.
Taking frequency.
Well,
it turns out that atoms are the best
choice for making tickers that always
take at the same frequency even Adams
have there,
uh,
um,
imperfections.
Temperature means that the atoms are
moving with a certain velocity,
having a certain kinetic energy.
The hotter the gas is,
the faster the atoms are moving.
It's not so easy to measure the ticking
frequency of something that's whizzing
around at the speed of sound.
And that's the problem that everybody
was facing with atomic clocks was the
Adams are moving at approximately the
speed of sound and it wasn't so easy to
measure the taking frequency.
So we said,
let's call them down using lasers.
So they're going more slowly and that'll
make it easier to measure the taking
frequency and you can make better
clocks.
When I started doing laser cooling,
the very best clocks were accurate to a
part in 10 to the 13th.
So that's one part divided by one with
13 zero,
zero effort.
That's the fractional error in how good
that clock was.
Sounds incredible,
right?
But today those clocks are a couple
intended,
the 16,
almost three orders of magnitude better.
And that has been made possible because
of laser cooling,
I suppose that young children are
curious about everything.
And very early,
my curiosity tended toward a curiosity
about science.
My parents got me a microscope when I
was very young,
maybe six years old.
And I remember looking at all kinds of
things around the house,
uh,
with this microscope.
I remember collecting various household,
uh,
chemicals and fluids to mix together,
which was my homemade chemistry set,
and in addition,
I was doing all the other things that
kids do,
climb trees and uh,
uh,
a scary up and down a cliffs and a
clicked a huckleberries in the woods.
Uh,
but,
um,
uh,
there was always a lot of physical
activity and a lot of that physical
activity for me involved,
uh,
doing things that,
that related to science,
looking at stuff,
being curious,
curious about the natural world.
That's a really interesting question.
Um,
and um,
sadly the answer isn't simple.
The simple answer is no,
but now I've got to explain why I'm
saying that the answer is no.
The answer is that every process for
cooling either also introduces the
possibility that you can introduce some
extra energy into the system.
You see,
cooling means taking energy out and
heating means putting energy in.
But in order to take energy out,
then it turns out that you opened the
door for energy to go in,
take laser cooling.
Laser cooling takes the energy out by
having an Adam coming along.
And then a photon hits the atom and
slows the Adam down.
Then that photon has to go someplace and
when that photon is shot out by the
atom,
the atom recoils and more energy goes
in.
So there's a balance between the cooling
and the heating and you can try to make
that balance work more and more in your
favor,
but you can never make it work.
One hundred percent cooling and no
heating.
So that's one of the reasons why you
don't expect to ever get to absolute
zero.
On the other hand,
what does it mean to be an absolute
zero?
It means that all the thermal motion
stops.
Well,
I can take one,
Adam and I can take as much energy out
of it as possible so that it's in what
we would call the ground state.
The lowest possible state of energy.
Is it absolute zero?
Not really,
because in order to be at absolute zero,
I really have to have a whole bundle of
things.
I can't really talk easily about the
temperature of a single object.
I should really talk about a whole
ensemble and if I do that with a whole
bunch of atoms,
what's going to happen is maybe if I'm
lucky,
maybe 99 percent of them are going to be
in the ground state and then one percent
isn't,
so it's not absolute zero.
I can't come up with any procedure that
is going to say 100 percent of the time
this Adam's going to end up in the
ground state and that's what I would
need to be able to claim that I'd really
gotten to absolute zero,
but on the other hand,
I can get so close to absolute zero that
for many experiments it's basically
absolutely zero for all practical
purposes,
but not for all experiments and we're
constantly working on trying to make
things colder because for some
experiments it really matters that we're
not quite there.
Well,
my reaction to hearing about the Nobel
prize was one of
a shock and disbelief.
In fact,
I can remember very,
very well when this happened.
I was attending a meeting in California
meeting of the American Physical Society
and the Optical Society of America
meeting jointly,
a out in California in Long Beach,
California.
And the day before the prizes were
announced,
a number of us were sitting around after
the scientific sessions were over
speculating about who was going to get
the Nobel prize that year.
And believe me,
nobody brought up my name.
Uh,
so later that night,
well,
it was the middle of the night,
uh,
that I got a call in my hotel room to
the effect that I had a shared the Nobel
prize with quad cone to new egg.
And Steve Chu came as a complete shock.
My life changed dramatically.
Um,
uh,
it's very difficult for me to keep up
with all of the invitations that I get
to speak about my work.
I'm a,
the size of my research group has,
has grown.
That's made it possible for me to be
involved in more and more new kinds of
physics.
But it's made it harder and harder for
me to be intimately familiar with all
the things that are going on.
So there's a kind of a,
of a tension between the joy in doing
lots of new things and the desire to
understand them better and better.
Um,
another thing that I never would have
imagined would have been a,
one of the results of,
um,
becoming a Nobel laureate is that I
ended up meeting people who are actually
famous.
So,
you know,
people say,
Oh,
you're a Nobel laureate,
you must be famous.
No,
nobody remembers,
you know,
outside of the field in which working.
Nobody remembers who won the Nobel prize
a even a couple of years ago.
Uh,
but as a result of being a Nobel
laureate,
I get invited to a,
uh,
to things where I've met people who are
actually famous.
One of the people that I have met who
has been most charming,
uh,
is Dr Ruth Westheimer.
Uh,
she lives in New York City and uh,
I see her probably about once a year and
she's just a wonderfully warm and
genuine person.
Just,
just a,
just a joy to know as a friend.
Well,
first of all,
I should say that I,
I'm not particularly comfortable with
being described as a religious person
because somehow I have this image in my
mind of,
of somebody who's who's very proper and
prim and follows all sorts of rituals
and stuff.
And,
and I,
I liked rather to describe myself as a
person of faith.
Um,
and uh,
clearly I don't believe that science has
made belief in God obsolete or else I
wouldn't describe myself as a person of
faith.
Uh,
I believe that certain ways of
interpreting a certain scriptures have
been made obsolete by science,
but that in no way makes religious faith
or belief in God obsolete.
It just requires what I would consider
to be a,
a,
a different outlook of maturation of
religious faith.
But if we look at the history of
religious faith as told in the
scriptures and as seen throughout
history,
I think the entire history of faith has
been one of a maturation of that faith.
I see it not so much as people becoming
more mature in their faith,
but God challenging people to become
more mature,
to get a clear understanding of what God
wants for humankind,
and I think God is always pushing us to
be better than what we are.
Okay,
so there's two ways of answering that
question.
By and large science and religion deal
with different kinds of questions.
Science deals with questions about how
things come to be the way they are.
How should I think about the way things
are?
How shall I organize my understanding of
the way things behave?
Whereas religion deals with questions
like,
how should I behave toward my fellow
human creatures?
What should my relationship be to God?
How should I understand the ultimate
origins of this world in this universe
in which we live is a very different
kinds of questions,
but sometimes the areas that science
addresses and the areas that our
religion addresses can overlap.
So I don't ascribe to the idea of
science and religion as being non
overlapping.
Magisterial has sometimes been
described,
but I also will say that by and large,
they deal with different kinds of
questions,
but there are ethical questions that
might involve things like medical ethics
or environmental questions where you
have to understand the science in order
to be able to make good ethical
decisions that are guided by your
religious principles.
So there's always going to be places
where science and religion are gonna
come to bear on the same kinds of
problems
all the time.
In fact,
it's one of the greatest things about
being a scientist is that you're
continually surprised.
Nature is so much more clever than we
are that we never understand the secrets
that nature has to has to offer.
But little by little we learned more and
more,
but every time we go into the
laboratory,
we're surprised.
I work in an area of physics,
atomic physics,
where the basic principles,
as far as we know,
the basic principles were pretty much
understood in the 19 thirties.
Maybe some details were worked out in
the forties and fifties,
but we are still surprised everyday by
the results of these things.
So.
So in spite of the fact that some people
might say,
well,
there's nothing new,
we're surprised every day and the things
we learned were things that nobody
imagined that things would work this
way.
So for example,
let's go back to this example about
laser cooling.
Everybody thought they understood how
cold you could get things using laser
cooling and the problem was as simple
enough problem,
you can write down the proof and in a
few minutes as to how cold is possible,
get something.
And we got it eventually,
200 times colder for,
for one particular item.
Then the theory said was possible.
Why?
Well,
because the situation was a little bit
more complicated.
Remember I said that physicists like to,
uh,
make a problem really simple.
That's the physicist way of looking at a
problem.
Well,
Einstein once said,
a problem should be made as simple as
possible,
but no simpler.
And sometimes you make a mistake and
you'll leave out some really important
stuff.
Usually when you do that,
it makes things worse.
This was a case where putting in the
complications made things work better.
Nobody would have guessed that that was
gonna happen.
I can't imagine anybody sitting down and
thinking,
okay,
we're going to figure out how laser
cooling works and coming up with what
actually happens.
We had to do the experiments first.
Nature showed us what was,
what was gonna happen,
and then clever people figured out what
was really going on.
Kinds of surprises happen to us all the
time.